warning this video contains cold B ah
spoilers all the spoilers all of them
what is up everybody its Anna Mac here
for anime uproar and welcome to a
brand-new Code Geass video and yes I am
wearing another Columbia Jersey in this
video we're going to be counting down
the top 10 unsolved mysteries in the
world of Code Geass and I want to thank
everyone who helped us create this video
by taking part in our livestream and in
our discord chat if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe and click
that notification bell for all the
latest Code Geass season 3 news and
theories and if you want to chat with us
on a daily basis you can join our
discord server the link is in the
description and without further ado
mystery number 10
how many code bearers are there in the
world and related to that can code
bearers reproduce can they have children
in the original code geass series we
know that there are at least two living
code bearers C 2 and V 2 and if we read
the Renia of the darkness manga we
learned that at least one more code
exists YouTube so there is at least
three codes existing at the same time
within the world of kochiya so we know
of at least three codes existing at the
same time in the world of Code Geass and
we also know that Charles needed two
codes in order to activate the Ragnarok
connection but we don't know if there
are any other codes out there there
could be only the three or there could
be a lot more now a lot of people have
been talking about in the comments to
our videos and on our discord server
about the possibility of c2 and Lelouch
having children
however while that sounds really cool
there is no known example in the world
of Code Geass for someone with code
actually having children the nun that
gave C to her code was a nun so we can
assume she doesn't have children
v2 got his code when he was still a
child so we can assume that he cannot
have children we don't know that we
don't think that c2 has any children and
of course Charles had all of his many
children before he got code so we don't
know if someone who has code can
actually procreate there is also no
evidence in the manga or any other Code
Geass spin-off about code bearers having
children and it's myths about other
immortal beings like vampires are
anything to go on except for Twilight in
more
usually cannot procreate so yeah I don't
know we'll have to wait and see but it
would be pretty freaking kawaii for
Lelouch and c2 to have a baby
thanks to know digit for contributing on
this one mystery number 9 what is the
true purpose of the thought elevators we
know that there are 8 thought elevators
scattered around the world that they
were created by a mysterious ancient
civilization and that Charles uses them
to activate the Ragnarok connection now
my theory is that the name of this
ancient civilization is the runner s and
that they use the salt elevators to
create a first Ragnarok connection which
allows them to progress beyond physical
form and create the world of C which is
essentially an artificial afterlife
which allows every human consciousness
after death to join this collective
consciousness I believe that what
Charles wanted to do was create a second
Ragnarok connection which would destroy
the barrier between the world of Z and
humans who are currently alive and
ensure that humans who are currently
alive join the collective
unconsciousness before dying for a more
detailed analysis about the Roger s and
what I think was childish true plan you
can check out our top 5 hidden messages
in code geass video but the question
remains other than creating the Ragnarok
connection is there some other purpose
to the thought elevators can they do
other things like allow human beings to
communicate with the dead as Charles
seems to imply when he says that he
spoke to Prince Clovis after Clovis is
that the true purpose of the thought
elevators is that's only a mystery that
I want to see resolved in the sequel
thanks to soul maka for contributing to
this one mystery number 8 what is the
significance of the planet Jupiter in
the sequence where Lelouch first gets
his Geass we see a frame that appears to
show the planet Jupiter and we see
Jupiter even more clearly in the
sequence where his memories are finally
restored after Charles brainwash them at
the beginning of r2 we also see Jupiter
inside the world of Z where it is
supposed to represent the collective
unconscious or God
but why Jupiter why not a different
planet or a fictional planet why an
exact copy of Jupiter at this point we
really
and be sure but we can turn to Austral
adji and roman mythology for some
answers if we look at astrology calm
Jupiter is defined as the thinking
persons planet as the guardian of the
abstract mind this planet rules higher
learning and bestows upon us a yen for
exploring ideas both intellectually and
spiritually intellectually speaking
Jupiter assists us in formulating our
ideology in the more spiritual realm
Jupiter Lords over religion and
philosophy so if Jupiter inside the
world of sea is supposed to represent
God or the collective unconscious it
makes sense that a planet which
symbolizes abstract thinking religion
and philosophy would be the symbol for
God inside the world of sea and if we
look at Roman mythology Jupiter is the
god of the sky and thunder and the king
of the gods in ancient Roman religion as
the sky God he was a divine witness to
hold the sacred trust on which justice
and good government depends the symbols
for Jupiter include Thunderbolts and the
eagle and we know that the EOS symbol
kind of looks like a combination of a
thunderbolt and a bird in flight which
is pretty interesting Jupiter was
sometimes called the beam or Shaq that
supports and holds together the universe
and he who has the power of conquering
anything so since we know he has the
power of Kings and Jupiter is the king
of God it makes sense to use this planet
as the symbol for the world of see
although we don't know if there is some
other deeper meaning behind using
Jupiter once again thanks no digit for
contributing to this one mystery number
seven why is Australia shown as separate
on every map in the world of code geass
this is a mystery that is very dear to
my own heart and it has become a big
meme on our discord server but I really
do wonder why Australia is constantly
shown as separate on every map in the
world of code geass and why does mal
when he threatened to kidnap c2 say that
he wants to escape to Australia and take
her to Australia with him this implies
that Australia is a good place to hide
in the world of Rodia
so the question is why was it never
taken over or
occurred by de Bretagne or any other
military alliance even though it has
ample land and resources is Australia
defended by powerful Geass users does it
have some sort of special weapons our
despite is just that annoying that
people simply refuse to colonize
Australia all of these questions are
really interesting and I hope that we
learn more about this in the sequel and
again for a more detailed analysis of
the Australia mystery you can check out
our top five hidden messages in the
world of Code Geass the link is in the
description thanks to Helen from the
discord for contributing to this one
mystery number six will the Middle East
come into play in the code geass sequel
we know that in the world of code he has
the middle east and especially the iran
iraq area has its own thought elevator
and we also see that in this map this
region is marked separate in pink we
also know that in the back of the code
geass ex clamp mutuality artbook which
was first published in 2008 by Kadokawa
Shoten there is a short story that takes
place in baghdad in this story Lelouch
Suzaku and c2 are shown in a scene
together and Lelouch and Suzaku are
shown actually planning for the zero
Requiem we also know that the new Code
Geass sequel TV shows two people riding
camels in a middle-eastern landscape
again pointing to the idea that the
Middle East might play some role in the
sequel so yeah the Middle East keeps
coming up in the original series in this
little short story that was published in
2008 and in the PV and so I wonder if
something important is going to happen
surrounding that specific thought
elevator crobat Gul canard discord made
a video about this question a while back
so I will leave that link in the
description and also thanks to Lulu TM
for contributing to this one mystery
number 5 how did shin Hyuga Chiang the
main villain of Akito the exiled get his
Geass from a vision of a skull rather
than from a regular code bear unlike
every other Geass user in the world of
Code Geass shin appears to receive his
Geass not from a regular code bearer but
from a vision of a skull that does not
appear to have a physical form
the disco is actually a reference to
Shakespeare's play Hamlet because we
know that shin just like Hamlet is
resentful of his mother's relationship
with a man other than his father and
both Hamlet and shin see ghostly visions
and struggle with their own sanity
before meeting a bloody end
now we just don't know how shin was able
to get his code this way but I have a
bit of a theory
Inaki to the exiled representative of
the collective consciousness tells us
that this collective consciousness can
interfere with the evolution of the
universe what if this collective
consciousness appeared to Shin as a
child after sensing his intent to murder
everyone in the world because he
believes that life is accursed and what
if they chose to gave him this Geass
power because they wanted to exterminate
the human race in the last episode of a
key to the Exile the representation of
the collective consciousness appears to
Layla and she actually tells Layla that
she believes that humans should not
possess Geass and that they should be
the Geass should be taken away from them
even at the cost of humans going extinct
however in episode 3 of our key to the
Exile this same being appears to general
SMIL us and tells him that she wants him
to kill Shin Hyuga Sheng so if it was
this collective consciousness this
non-physical being that gave Shin his
power in the first place in the form of
vision why would they then change their
mind and decide to kill him I believe
that either there are multiple factions
within the collective consciousness so
one faction might want to destroy
humanity while another doesn't or the
collective consciousness might have
changed its mind
after giving Shin his Geass we know that
the representation of the collective
consciousness tells Layla that her power
is unique and that Layla might actually
change the collective consciousness his
mind about humans being worthy of
possessing Gia so perhaps genuinely good
people like Layla actually changed the
collective consciousness his mind and
after giving Shin his power they decided
to take it away from him and to kill him
so that humanity does not go extinct
however the question that is why would
this powerful collective consciousness
not just destroy
on its own why would ask general villas
to do it for them and the answer to this
might be that having Geass power or code
may actually protect you or make you
immune from the collective consciousness
perhaps shin after receiving Geass could
no longer be harmed by the collective
consciousness so they needed someone
else an actual human to kill him in
their place this is all still a mystery
of course and we can't know for sure but
I think that it would be interesting if
the collective consciousness plays a
part in the sequel if we learn that
someone with code or Geass is actually
immune to them and able to fight against
them despite their great immense power
of skull of the Geass on its forehead
also appears in a drawing for the Renia
of the darkness manga but even in this
manga we don't get any real answers so
what do you think how does shin get his
power what is this vision of a skull let
me know in the comments I'd love to hear
your theories mystery number four what
is Layla's blue Geass and how does it
actually work I recently made a detailed
video about blue Geass if you want to
check that out the link is in the
description but I will give a brief
summary right here I believe that Laila
PS is blue because her ultimate wish is
selfless all she wants is to protect
those she loves and she doesn't have any
ambitions of power destroying or
manipulating others in any way I also
believe that her power actually allows
her to connect the minds of those she
loved which creates a mini collective
consciousness and then this allows her
to alter physical reality as is
established in the final episode of
Aikido ta da I believe that this is also
why the representation of the collective
consciousness single Leila out as unique
because Leila's Geass power is to create
a mini collective consciousness with
great power
I want to thank Marvin for nito for
actually helping me develop this theory
further in the comments to our blue
Geass video thanks bro mystery number
three can someone have both code and
Geass or different types of Geass at the
same time there is a very interesting
theory out there that Lelouch in the
sequel will have both code and Geass
because he receives his code from
Charles but he received his Geass
see - and because c2 is still alive that
means that his contract is still valid
but if this is the case if he possesses
both then how would this work will the
lucious Geass work differently if this
is the case and will it look differently
there are a lot of rumors going around
about Lelouch having green Geass and
blue Geass in the new Code Geass equal P
V and we can't know for sure because we
don't have the full PV yet however I
think this is an interesting mystery and
I'm also wondering if having both code
and yes for different types of Geass or
what-have-you
will actually change lucious personality
will he become somewhat different now
because we know that when c2 loses her
memories she actually acts completely
differently than the c2 we know after
she gets cold this is definitely a
mystery that I want to see resolved in
the sequel and my thanks to gwanak
section and humble isa chief for helping
out on this one mystery number two what
is SI toos real name now this is one of
the most frustrating Code Geass
mysteries for me personally because I
really want to know c2 is real name when
never see - his real name is mentioned
in Code Geass the sound is taken out and
replaced by a drop of water so there is
no real way for us to know what her name
is we have to wait until season 3 and
hopefully find out however an
interesting theory was brought up in our
last Code Geass livestream by beta
reader who suggested a SI toos name
could be Brennen now Brennan is an Irish
female name and we know that Geass
mythology comes from Ireland the place
where she lived in her childhood it
could be Ireland judging by the
architecture now this given name Brennan
it's considered to be mainly Irish for
Gaelic and the meaning is derived from
the Irish brawn meaning moisture or drop
this is a really interesting theory for
me personally because it could explain
the whole water drop thing in the
original show and we know that Geass
comes from the Irish mythology of geese
which is a specific obligation or
prohibition similar to being under a vow
or a spell
it is women who plays Geass upon men and
in some cases the woman turns out to be
a goddess or an immortal which not to
mention that Sita's hair color is green
which is the national color of Ireland
so yeah I really like this theory I find
it interesting do you guys think that c2
could be Irish and that her name could
be Brennan personally she looks more
like a Catherine or something like that
to me but I still really like beta
readers theory if you have any theories
of your own or what c2 is real name is
share them in the comments because I'd
love to hear from you and remember in
the Renia of the darkness manga we
learned that a person named shiri
gains the code v2 so it could mean that
the initials V and C don't actually mean
anything
C twos name might not start with C at
all and the number one unsolved mystery
in the world of code geass the one
mystery that everything else hangs on is
of course the actual origin of code and
giya where to quote and Geass come from
were they created by the ancient
civilization along with the thought
elevators or did they always exist in
that world kind of like alchemy in the
world of full metal alchemist how do
code and Geass really work what are
their limitations what is their true
purpose these are all questions that we
only get very vague answers to in Korea
so far thanks to old Wayne for
contributing to this one and yeah this
is something that I really want to know
more about I want to know about the
origins of this world about the origins
of code and Geass and I can't wait to
see how it all ties into the sequel and
that's it for this video as always thank
you all so much for watching and for
your amazing support if you enjoyed
these videos be sure to LIKE and
subscribe and make sure you click that
notification bell so you can be the
first to know every time we get breaking
news about code geass season 3 and if
you want to chat with us on a daily
basis you can join our discord server
the link is in the description and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]